Bitte schön.
Ja, hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag. Sind Sie der Herr Doktor?
Ja, ich bin Doktor. Ich heiße Ibrahim Usta.
Und ich bin heute so ständig Arzt für Sie.
Und ich möchte mit Ihnen eine Aufnahmegespräche durchführen.
Aber bevor wir über aktuelle Bescheiden sprechen,
muss ich ganz schnell allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Danach kommen wir jetzt zu Ihren aktuellen Bescheiden.
Sind Sie damit einfach damit?
Herr Doktor, ich habe, ich bekomme ganz schlecht Luftzeit gestern.
Ich habe so einen Druck auf den Brustsatz.
Es fällt mir schwer, mit Ihnen zu sprechen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir erstmal reden sollen
oder ob Sie mich zuerst untersuchen wollen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie ganz genau.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Brustschirmens?
Gestern Abend.
Seit gestern Abend?
Und gab es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte
Ernne Bescheiden oder zum Erzimmer?
Ich habe vor zehn Jahren ungefähr einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Damals habe ich einen Herzkatheter bekommen.
Und seitdem dringend war ich ganz gut.
Ich war auch jetzt vor zwei Monaten beim Kardiologen zu Kontrolle.
Es war alles in Ordnung, aber irgendwie ist mir sein Gestern Abend nicht gut.
Deswegen bin ich heute da.
Bekommen Sie schwer Luft?
Ja, es fällt mir schwer.
Insbesondere, wenn ich ein paar Schritte laufe.
Sie sehen, mein Gesicht ist auch ganz blass.
Ich schwitze auch, es ist so kaltschweißig.
Ja, wie heißt er sich denn?
Mein Name ist Klaus Burgmeister.
Burgmeister.
Burg, B-U-R-G.
Meister.
Burgmeister.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
82 Jahre alt.
82.
80 Jahre alt.
Okay, und wann sind Sie noch geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. April 1941.
1941.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Burgmeister?
Ich bin circa 1,72 m.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Mein Gewicht sind ungefähr 75 kg.
75 kg.
Und Herr Burgmeister, ich muss schnell das Anämpfergespräch unterbrechen.
Und danach schraube ich einen EKG.
Ich möchte die Metallparameter überprüfen.
Und danach kommen wir jetzt, diese Gespräche weiterführen.
Okay.
Also, wir haben eine Sausstoffsättigung von 93.
93.
Im EKG haben wir ein Sinus-Rhythmus.
Sinus-Rhythmus.
Fulz 70.
Blutdruck 100 zu 60.
60.
Und keine Akute in Fargzeichen.
Also keine ST-Hebung und keine Senkung.
Okay.
Und Troponin-Test ist negativ.
Und Herr Burgmeister, haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Speziell jetzt nicht.
Ich habe eine regelmäßige Medikamente, wie immer ein.
Ich bin heute zu Ihnen gekommen, weil es mir nicht so gut geht.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein? Normalerweise?
Ich habe aspirin 100.
Ja.
Eine Organs?
Mittags, nehme ich eine.
Okay.
Ich nehme Ramipri 5 mg, eine morgens.
Ja.
Ich nehme Amnudipine, 5 mg morgens und Avins.
Ich nehme Ennalap...
Nein, nicht...
Eplerinon.
Ich glaube, das sind 10 mg eine.
10 mg morgens?
Ja.
Okay.
Und dann nehme ich etwas Polystyrene senken.
Polystyrene?
Atorvastatin 40 mg.
40 mg.
Also, habe ich noch eins, ein Betablocker, das nennt sich Metaprolol 47,5.
Ja.
Eine morgens, eine Abend.
Abend.
Nehmen Sie Klopidograldatikakrolol 1? Nein.
Okay.
Und das war alles, ne?
Die Medikamente, ja.
Ja, die Medikamente, okay.
Okay.
Und gibt es andere Bescheiden, die hauptscheidwerden begleiten?
Ja, ich merke, dass auch hier meine linke Schulter und meine linke Arme, da habe ich auch Schmerzen seit gestern.
Ja.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe immer wieder so ein bisschen Kalsschweißigkeit.
Wenn ich mich im Spiegel anschaue, sehe ich sehr blass aus.
Also, es geht mir eigentlich nicht so gut. Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Und wie stark die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10 und wobei eine sehr leicht und 10 sehr ausordnete stark Schmerzen entspricht.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Man mehr mal weniger, aber das stärkste war, würde ich sagen, bei 4, 5.
Und wenn Sie Borussia-Schmerzen bekommen, wie viel, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie hat ich ja gesagt, also manchmal sehr stark, manchmal nur sehr leicht.
Ja, okay.
Und starren die Schmerzen nur in linke Arme?
Im Moment, ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie die Schmerzen immer verschlechter seit gestern?
Nicht unbedingt. Es ist mal stärker, mal weniger stark, aber schlimmer ist es jetzt nicht gewonnen, aber es ist halt nachanhaltend.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen, Herr Bürgmeister?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, Durchfall habe ich auch nicht, aber so eine leichte Übelkeit spüre ich schon, ja.
Übelkeit.
Okay. Und haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Fieber habe ich nicht, nein.
Ja. Okay.
Und haben Sie, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Kalten, Kalten Schweiz bekommen?
Ja.
Und seit gestern?
Ja, seit gestern.
Okay.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie in Ihren Beinen, Ödem oder Wasser eine Lagerung bemerken?
Ach so, nein, das habe ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Ödem an meinen Beinen habe ich bisher nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Alles gut, alles gleich geblieben.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Ja, das ist normal, das ist ja ganz in Ordnung, da gibt es kein Problem.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Und mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, ist auch alles in Ordnung.
Ja, okay.
Und letzte Frage, und haben Sie Probleme ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, gut.
Jetzt wird es mal wieder üblich.
Ich glaube, ich werde jetzt bewusstlos.
Und ich würde Sie bitte zur Oxigen geben.
Ja, okay.
Danke schön.
Und würden Sie bitte zur Stoffgabe geben?
Nein, wir legen die Schockposition bei der Hochlagierung.
Und der Zugang, wenn wir diese Schock besiegen.
Und, sorry, gut.
Und wir alarmieren Geld.
Und wir müssen eine Sauerstoffgabe geben.
Hallo Doktor.
Ja, hallo.
Was ist passiert?
Ja, Sie werden ohne...
Ich komme ganz schlecht, Luft, Herr Doktor.
Ach, kurz.
Ich habe so einen Druck auf der Brust im Moment.
Ja, und wir haben Ihnen ein Saustoff geben.
Okay.
Und Sie sind unmächtig geworden.
Aber machen Sie keine Sorge, machen Sie keine Sorge bitte.
Und wir würden alle Massnahmen eingegriffen.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt geht es wieder etwas besser.
Ja, okay.
Gott sei Dank.
Und würden...
Was ist das?
Ist das ja eine Infusion?
Ja.
Das ist eine Flüssigkeit.
Okay.
Und würden wir das eine andere Gespräche durchführen?
Weiterführen?
Wir haben doch jetzt eine EKG geschrieben, oder?
Ja.
Was sieht man in der EKG?
Eine Hebung in 2, 3, AVF.
Ja, okay.
Und wir müssen jetzt ein Kardiologiekonzyr beantragen.
Das ist ein Notfall.
Okay, Baruch.
Was habe ich denn, Herr Doktor?
Sie haben ein Myokatinfarkt bekommen.
Oh, doch.
Herzschlag, ja.
Das ist ein Notfall.
Wir müssen sofort...
Angiografie...
Was ist das?
Angiografie?
Angiografie...
Angiografie ist um...
Meine...
Ein Herzkatheter.
Ja, Herzkatheter.
Ach so, ja, das habe ich schon mal gehabt.
Okay, das kenne ich, ja.
Wir müssen sofort wieder durchführen.
Herzkatheter.
Ja, ich bin damit einverstanden, ja.
Okay.
Und wir müssen sofort 300 Milligramm Asperin
und 600 Klopidogrel geben.
Und wir müssen Enoxoparin 0,8 geben.
Sie sind Herr Doktor.
Wenn Sie das für richtig halten, dann würde ich gerne.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Okay, jetzt geht es mir wieder ein bisschen etwas besser.
Die Luft wird auch besser.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Und jetzt würden wir Anamnesie-Gespräch weiterführen?
Im Moment, bis der Herzkatheter kommt, können wir gerne weitermachen.
Normalerweise muss der Patient, wie jetzt eigentlich zum Kardälogen,
direkt ins Herzkatheter, akut, infarkt, auf die Trage,
unter Herzkontrolle direkt in Herzkatheter.
Ja.
Okay, wir machen jetzt die Anamnesie weiter,
damit sie ihr Gespräch fortführen können.
Okay.
Und Herr Buchmeister, nun würde ich Sie mit Ihnen über Ihre Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Bitte schön, ja.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie an chronischen oder wichtigen Erkronischen?
Ja, ich habe seit über 20 Jahren eine Spinalkanal-Sthenose
und deswegen habe ich immer starke Schmerzen in beiden Beinen.
Ja.
Deswegen immer wieder Schmerzen-Medikamente nehmen muss.
Was sind die Medikamente?
Wie sind sie?
Ja, das ist Ibuprofen oder Novalgien, je nach Themen,
wie stark die Schmerzen sind.
Okay.
Ibuprofen, kennen Sie da die Dosierung?
Die letzten meisten 600 Milligramm.
600 Milligramm meisten.
Okay.
Und andere Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Also ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck,
seit über 30 Jahren.
30 Jahre.
Und habe Probleme auch mit meinen beiden Knien,
da habe ich Arthrose.
Ja, beiden Knien.
Der Autopäde sagt, die müssen operiert werden,
aber ich will keine Operation.
Okay.
Und ich möchte jetzt nach Ihrer Familienvorgeschichte fragen.
Ja.
Okay.
Leiden Sie, leiden Ihr Vater oder Ihre Mutter an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Oder sind die Eltern noch?
Nein, nein, die sind beide schon verstorben.
Und woran, und wann sind sie verstorben?
Gut, das ist jetzt auch schon 20 Jahre her.
Ja.
Mein Vater hatte ein Brust-Aterkrebs,
aber ist auch einen Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Ja.
Und meine Mutter hatte dann einen Schlaganfang.
Beide vor 20 Jahren?
Ungefähr, ja.
Und woran ist Ihre Mutter verstorben?
Er hatte einen Schlaganfang.
Schlaganfang.
Okay, Schlaganfang.
Und haben Sie Geschwister, Herr Buchmeister?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Und ist sie gesund?
Sie ist circa 70 Jahre alt, aber sie hat auch einige Erkrankungen,
aber das hat sie so weit gut im Griff.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien?
Ich habe einige Polenallergien, aber sonst nicht.
Polenallergien?
Und was machen Sie?
Sonst nichts.
Ja, okay.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Buchmeister?
Nein.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr sehr.
Sehr sehr, sehr gut.
Okay.
Und, okay, und was machen Sie beruflich?
Renten, oder?
Ich bin natürlich Rentner, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Schreiner gearbeitet.
Schreiner.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Die sind glücklicherweise gesund, ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Und wohnen Sie allein, oder?
Nein, mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Okay, ich habe meine alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Und ich wünsche Ihnen gute Besserung im Aufnahme.
So, jetzt geht es in der Data.
Okay, gut.
Ich habe ein Kollege, der eine andere Frage.
Was ist ein Code gelb?
Ich weiß nicht, welchen Code es ist.
Ich habe es mir missverkürzt.
Ich bin ein Nachrichter.
Iain, Sie sind gut.
Ich bin ein Kollege, der ein Code gelb.
Ich weiß nicht, welchen Code es ist.
Ich habe ein Code gelb.
Dann muss man Herzdruckmassage gleich aussehen.
Okay, dann nochmal Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Hallo, Kollegen.
Ja, ich bin der Oberarzt. Guten Tag.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt. Ich heiße Ibrahim Uster.
Ich möchte einen Patienten vorstellen.
Natürlich, bitte schön.
Es geht um Klaus Brugmeister, der 82 Jahre alt ist.
Er ist April 22, 1941 geboren.
Er ist 1,72 Meter groß, 75 kg schwer.
Und Klaus Brugmeister hat sich bei uns seit gestern bestehende Retro-Sternale Brutschmerzen vorgestellt.
Er hat sich mit einem akuten Corona-Syndrom vorgestellt.
Er hat uns vorgestellt und kam während der Untersuchung in einen Kandylgen-Shock.
Kann man das so kurz machen oder müsste das so ausführlich mit den Symptomen machen jetzt bei der Prüfung?
Ich denke, Ihre Empfehlung ist besser, am besten.
Aber diese Notfall-Situation ist sehr selten in der Prüfung.
Manchmal sagen wir auch, dass ein Genephektor ist.
Er stellt sich in den Spruch.
Das ist jetzt eine instabile, angenehme Präkteris.
Der Patient hat erst mal nur Luftnoten gesagt.
Wir haben gesagt, dass er sich bei uns seit gestern bestehenden Dispene und Angene-Pektor ist.
Er hat ihn vorgestellt.
Die Diagnose kommt dann am Schluss.
Ich denke, diese.
Also Symptome und Diagnose.
Der Patient hat über die Übelkeit und Kaltenschweiß geblieben.
Die Fragen nach Luftfall, Fieber, Gebietverlust und Apathetologik wurden bei den Patienten verneint.
Die Brustschmerzen strahlen in den Rücken aus.
Die Schmerzintensität ist auf eine Schmerzkasse bei Ruhe und Belastung.
Der Patient nimmt 100 mg Asperin mit Tags, einmal pro Tag und Ramipril, 5 mg, morgens und am Lodipin, 5 mg, morgens und abends, 2 Mal pro Tag.
Er hat 10 mg Aplerin und 40 mg Atobastatin, 40 mg, 1 mg Metachlorol, 47,5 mg, morgens und abends.
In der Familie von einem Neese finden sich in seiner Vorgeschichte Gab es eine Spinalchdenose seit 20 Jahren.
Er hat die in beiden Beinen ausgetragen und eine Atelierle Hypatonie seit über 30 Jahren.
Er hat in beiden Beinen keine Bonatose.
Er hat eine Prostatokarsinone und Möckardinfarkt beim Vater, der vor 20 Jahren an Emae gestorben ist.
Er hat eine Apoplex bei der Mutter, die vor 20 Jahren an Gehirn in Zulch, apoplex gestorben ist.
Der Patient ist nicht rauchig und trinkt selten Alkohol.
Er ist ein Polinist, social-anomnistisch, ist eher Rentner, aber vorher schreien und hat 2 Kinder und lebt mit seiner Frau.
Aufgrund dieses Rhythmatik gehe ich von einer Möckardinfarkt aus.
Er hat ein akutes Chronaseutronen mit Hebungen oder ein positiver Troponintest.
Er hat den Patienten vorgestellt.
Er hat einen Intensivstationen und hat einen Intensivstationen.
Er hat einen Intensivstationen mit einem Intensivstationen.
Hier kommen ein paar Tipps.
Hier kommen zwei Tipps.